I've been homeless in 2015 at the height
of the refugee crisis people just wanna
get little so they're pushing a lot we
travelled alongside hundreds of
thousands of asylum seekers who poured
into Europe seeking refuge hundreds of
people are still lined up here and they
thought that the border here with
Germany was going to open over 1 million
people entered Europe in one year most
were fleeing war and conflict many
risking their lives by taking dangerous
journeys across the Aegean Sea Europe's
borders have closed and a deal struck
between the EU and Turkey last year has
slowed the flow of people crossing the
sea to a trickle refugees in Greece are
now trapped here waiting desperately for
asylum washed ashore 11th Rollo Emanuel
Ax a man on a few stuck in greek camps
have grown so hopeless they've taken
their own lives we witnessed the limbo
of refugees stuck on lesbos and joined
the Greeks still compelled to help them
now things are relatively calm at the
moment we don't know what it's happened
this is what aid workers call the life
jacket graveyard thousands upon
thousands of discarded life jackets
rafts and clothing that refugees left
behind a stark reminder of the magnitude
of the crisis at the highest point over
there it looks like it's at least 12
feet tall and you know here's an example
of one that's meant for a small child or
a baby but it actually says not for use
in boating so this isn't even meant to
be used for someone in a situation like
a refugee fleeing on a boat that's
pretty consistent with some of the
reporting that we've done on life
jackets that were actually made out of
straw and caused a lot of people to
drown so it's insane being here and
thinking that every single one of these
articles of lifejackets or the rafts are
associated with so many refugee stories
[Music]
stories that are still ending tragically
just a few weeks before we arrived at
least eight refugees died in a shipwreck
off the North Coast Greek nonprofits
like the Emergency Response Center
International are continuing to train
volunteers for rescue missions 1 2 3 ok
we have him here so you're like pull
dear old images here we have the medic
he will take the headway and he will
stop CPR if it's necessary nassos
traveled here from athens planning to
stay for 15 days that was a year and a
half ago yeah it's the feelings are so
strong and you can you can leave you can
leave I mean you have a gap if you leave
there is a gap inside you so that's why
sorrow is one of the volunteers nassos
mentors she's a Syrian refugee who
survived the treacherous journey herself
I cross from the same area here in
August 2015 with my my sister she was 17
years old so yeah I can I can understand
where's everybody been through here
every day
I wasn't my sister and like a dinky and
it was like for seven people and we've
been 20 we just like John Lennon on you
start passing and then after 15 minute
the engine stop my dad friend he was at
us in the boat he came up with the idea
why we don't jump inside the water and
hold the ropes to make it heavier from
the side but lighter from inside
it was scary is so scared for me to jump
in the water and then 10 minute later my
sister jump in the water and that's
freaked me out more because my sister
wear glasses and if she take it off she
might get dizzy and lose her hands and
lose the boat and if she like just loved
the boat I care and follow her because I
would literally be dying also in the
middle of the sea we continue like this
for Lennie
the next three and half hours and then
we make it Chris and felt like dream we
didn't believe till this day we don't
believe what happened with us like the
human being mind can't imagine this
thing even for me I don't I talk about
it but I don't really believe it that I
was doing this or I was in the boat and
it's not it's crazy
yes yes what would happen if you guys
didn't know how to swim he died solder
got asylum in Germany but she returned
to Greece to help others just like her
these days was less refugees that are
able to make it to Greece and part of
the reason why
because Turkish coast guards are
stopping any boats that they see setting
out from there but if the boats are able
to cross into Greek waters then they're
effectively safe and they're taken on to
Greece while there are far fewer boats
today some are still making it to the
Greek islands just to give you a sense
of the journey that thousands and
thousands of refugees have made in the
sea they come on rafts like this one
that's been abandoned here and is left
to shore and it's basically some plastic
and a wooden panel and there's a little
more to it I can't tell but it's by no
means anything sturdy or safe looking
[Music]
refugees told a Smuggler's still charged
between five hundred to three thousand
dollars per person to get on such rafts
the journey was so traumatic for these
Palestinian refugees who fled Syria that
for months they avoided the sea now they
come here daily to escape life in a
refugee camp but had been Lorna Judah
horn and shilling Hamlisch y-you know
you can study and I you Joe welcome Nick
yeah he had a heart come on he's over
the harbor no father Joe we've let the
TANF sit on octoroon
yes thousand and oxygen any cannabis
isn't such an ionic efficacy Ramon
Chavez mean the true model what I hadda
Miriam
Israel Bergman Bactria de la flora
Beamish mark or OPI nation auntie Angela
say I'm not Martin I'm inside the
station sacred Elena Jonnie Jonnie alan
tarver missouri Amparo
Kalani and Oh Kara Mustafa doli
no Conchita harp mulazim lilja
da da da da boo boo Hassan is a little
blood Alberto only other crystal not
stir up a damn the homes talk about
Elena had a net manic that she Annie oh
no mom Donna horn not a LeBaron sha
Allah Allah ha the shineth Minh
the family lives in cut a debit which is
one of the nicer refugee camps number 65
this is where they're living
this is where Hannah and her husband and
five children are staying in this one
container home oh hi and I'm doing that
it's audible not moon I'm a little glad
why not so I only accepted I had my wolf
on my field lost in the shuffle of
Athena and a minute a little bit left oh
they want to join relatives who made it
to Germany before the borders closed by
any means Yaya
hmm I'm Bella Italia I'm parrot Basra
and other machinery miss - hard and hi
pal haruka-san a cool hobby Michelle
knows a lot yeah it won't appear on my
stuff Farzana Karamoja hi cannabis Java
special a doctor yeah I kinda let me
Surya
eg Niebuhr millou - Mara sir
the sphere team at incision al North
Korea yeah Tamara no no Zara well Baja
Oh Gina
many people I wanted to live from
weekend and take houses jobs normal
lives the children at the school outside
job dignity that I want I don't I don't
like to keep my people over here like a
constant
Stavros marianas manages the Kara Tepe
camp for the municipality of lesbos I
tell you we don't give hops but we try
to support them in these difficult times
because believe me nobody want to stay
in my thing my village
so these guys found a snake in our
Tanner homes right here everybody
freaked out they started beating it to
kill it
we saw them pounding it right now and
he's carrying it over there it looks
like it's mostly dead
this all happened next to the home of
Miriam and habit who are Syrian refugees
well lalana ji Dilma sorry Willa riding
a koala ridin share best idea Gina and
Luis Roni Yarnell harm
Regina newsmen her a bus Sun sorry
Cynthia Ptolemy bit it nourish Karen in
the bomb Oh buddy Angela - - is partner
Oakland Oh Gina Latakia Turkey McCartney
AHA mustachio j1 sunny Leone I shove the
show's pawn the karateka they are shaft
or Georgia phenomenally Georgia - buddy
before a turkey s mama hey ma ma ma
Venus Madison a story on oh well Amara
Hospital La Marseillaise dork well track
IANA turkey a la da will ye see lesser
he can't Tokyo am i fat low in Surrey
Annessa Chumbley Georgiana under the
eu-turkey deal reached March 2016
refugees like habit are told to apply
for asylum in turkey instead of Greece
we questioned the European Asylum
support office which was brought in by
the EU to implement the deal I was just
talking to a Syrian man who is
originally from Homs
they escaped the war there and they said
their asylum application was rejected
and that it was recommended that they
vote a turkey but they've never lived in
Turkey before
and so we are here in order to implement
the you Turkey statement which means
that the first element of assessment is
whether a person should actually ask for
asylum not here but in Turkey because
that was the first state country where
they are i but it's not guaranteed that
they'll have asylum or protection in
Turkey like that's not for you guys to
guarantee okay so what the eu-turkey
statement actually discuss all the
result of it was that Turkey provided
guarantees concerning the treatment of
people in their territories on the basis
of these the Greek authorities are
taking decisions on whether people could
have the same claim process there the
agency recommends to Greek authorities
who should get asylum but it's been
criticized for unfair and hasty
assessments in fact Human Rights Watch
has documented violations in the asylum
procedure in the rush to implement the
eu-turkey deal and Amnesty International
told us that in Turkey some of the
refugees have been detained and denied
lawyers medical care and housing
[Music]
meanwhile in Greece the system remains
clogged and the UN official we spoke to
put the responsibility on the Greek
government we had a case not long ago
few weeks ago in heals Island where a
man self emulated because he felt too
anxious in there's a genuine need for
the government of Greece to further step
up and invest in a fast and efficient
asylum procedure we see significant
progress and that investment needs to be
doubled now the Greek asylum service
defended its efforts telling us they're
now faster at processing applications
than most EU Member States but they
admitted that refugees can wait up to a
year and for the refugees we met that's
far too long for now they're left to
deal with the nightmares of the past a
future that's uncertain and a present
that's becoming increasingly unbearable
hey guys it's Deena so this is what life
looks like now for Refugees trapped on
the Greek island of Lesbos next up we're
going to go to Germany where we'll catch
up with refugees who made it there and
see how their life is